welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today
there's been some interesting
developments taking place this week with
regards to North Korea and Donald Trump
earlier this week the president
announced that he was going to be
canceling Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
s visit to North Korea it was a
follow-up visit to the one that Trump
had a while back kind of the smooth
things over make sure everybody was on
the same page and that North Korea was
complying with the alleged deal that
Donald Trump made with them well he
decided after all of the evidence has
shown that his talk did no good in North
Korea is actually ramping up their
missile production capabilities he
decided he was gonna cancel Pompeo s
visit nonetheless he told reporters on
Wednesday this is a day or two after
canceling Pompeo s visit he said the
following he said I think we're doing
well with North Korea we'll have to see
I think we're doing well now if you're
paying attention following along at home
he actually said the same thing after it
was revealed that the actual puerto
rican death toll from hurricane maria
was close to three thousand people he
said i think we did a good job down
there uh yeah three thousand people died
by I think we did a good job yeah North
Korea talks fell apart they're making
missiles faster than ever now but I
think we did a good job I think things
are going well I'm just gonna cancel the
visit and then blame China for it he is
now also blaming China in addition to
hacking Hillary Clinton's emails China
is now the one responsible for tanking
the talks with North Korea and they're
doing it according to Trump because
they're mad about the trade wars that
really have not affected them whatsoever
it's mostly destroying things here at
home we're gonna talk about that a
little bit later in the show but he is
blaming China for just absolutely
everything right now and it has no basis
in reality if he wants to blame somebody
for the failed talk that he had with Kim
jong-un he needs to be blaming himself
something we know he's never gonna do
but I need I want to make something
clear here listen I am 100% for having
communication with North Korea and
getting them to denuclearize I believe
that we need to somehow get them to get
rid of this Kim jong-un regime to start
treating their people there with basic
dignity to stop locking up people for
being alleged political prisoners along
with their families and to start
providing for the people that live in
North Korea that are living in absolute
hellish conditions we need to do
something to make that happen not
military intervention but something so
that's why talks are okay but Trump's
talk with Kim jong-un did nothing other
than provide a photo-op so that he could
say I did something that other US
presidents were actually too smart to do
everyone knew that Kim jong-un was not
going to denuclearize I mean it was only
shortly after that our satellite footage
showed that oh yeah they're ramping up
their facilities they're upgrading their
facilities to make bigger better
missiles and by the way those missiles
are still pointed at the United States
so we got nothing out of it in North
Korea got everything because we did
agree to go ahead and stop those joint
military exercises with South Korea so
that we're not prepared anymore if North
Korea does something but again I I have
to stress this a hundred percent I do
not want any kind of military
intervention with North Korea and I do
want them to denuclearize just like I
want the United States to denuclearize
and every other country on the planet
that has these things to denuclearize
yet here we are as a country trying to
act like we have some kind of moral
authority policing everybody else's
nukes when we're the only people that
have ever dropped them on civilian
populations that was us that was the
United States we did that they haven't
done that you Russia hasn't done that
China hasn't done that nobody in the
Middle East has gone and dropped a nuke
on somebody
that's just us were the ones who did it
and yet we're mad now that other
countries are making this thing
everybody has to danique everybody
because if we're gonna sit here on what
I think 6600 nuclear weapons possibly
more than that and tell these other
groups hey you can't have these things
just us because we have to you know be
the deterrent in case anybody else does
it that's not how it works there needs
to be a global coalition to get rid of
these weapons once and for all something
like that is the only thing that could
possibly get a country like North Korea
to agree to give up these weapons but
it's not just about denuclearizing it's
about treating the people that live in
that country again under some of the
worst conditions on the planet treating
them like human beings providing them
with basic essentials like running water
and electricity which to many people in
that country don't even have access to I
mean you can see the the satellite
photos from outer space on North Korea
in the evening and there's barely any
light coming from anywhere other than
Pyongyang because nobody else even has
electricity they don't have that so yes
the people there need aid they need help
but Donald Trump is not going to be the
kind of guy that's going to offer that
and instead of trying to make things
better saying Kim what can we do to get
you to denuclearize do you want aid for
your people do you want do you want us
to bring in food we've got this big
surplus we're about to have to buy from
our farmers maybe we can help here maybe
we can get these people better maybe we
can help your country in exchange for
you giving up these weapons that seems
like the most humanitarian way to do
things which likely means that it's not
something we would ever even consider as
a country and that is very unfortunate